[Applaudissements]
le 3 février 2011 aux aurores les
policiers de Mar se déploi dans
plusieurs villes du
Québec ce matin ce n'est pas une frappe
comme les autres les suspects sont des
ingénieurs une MAE des chefs
d'entreprise des gens qui n'urai jamais
cru se retrouver dans une pare situation
mich nous devons vous informer que nous
sommes des policiers lesciers arrête
deux employés du groupe conseil roche
France Michot vice-présidente et un
autre ingénieur son collègue guetan
Morin tout ce que vous direz pourra être
pris par écrit et servir de preuve les
policiers arrêtent Claude Brière un
employé de la firme de gny BPR Triax et
un vice-président Roser
fontaine madame Sylvie
Saint-Jean à bois brillant les
enquêteurs font monter dans leur
autopatrouille l'ex-mairesse de la ville
Sylvie Saint-Jean vous avez le droit
d'avoir recours sans délai à
l'assistance de l'avocat de votre choix
avez-vous bien
compris le même sort attend Lino Zambito
et son père propriétaire de construction
infrabeec 2 mois plus tard un autre
ancien maire de boisbriant Robert
Poirier est
arrêté au Québec quand est accusé des
coupables les policiers confrontent les
suspects à la preuve mais tous se
demandent ce qu'ils font là
comme vous voyez je suis pas
impressionné je suis pas
impressionné mon à moi je suis pas
impressionné 17 mois d'enquête une
soixantaine de témoins et des milliers
de pages de documents ont mené à la mise
en accusation de H personnes liées à
l'usine d'puration des au de bois
brillant je su tellement surprise d'être
accusé d'abus de confiance d'avoir fait
de la FR
W nous avons obtenu une partie de la
preuve recueillie contre eux et nous
monons ce soir un aspect de l'histoire
un juge décidera plus tard de leur
culpabilité ou de leur innocence jamais
je ne volra à quelqu'un
jamais nous vous révélerons ce qui a
toutes les apparences d'un système
pernicieux qui mê fausse facture
collusion et enveloppe rempli d'argent
comptant ces allégations visent
principalement un fleuron du génie
Conseil québécois le groupe proche à qui
vous en avez donné des envis on en
donnait tout le temps régul partout mais
vous avez mais ça c'est normal tout le
monde a de l'argentir l'ouvrage les T
les films de génie on dit pas que c'est
votre firme qui est la source de tout ça
sauf que le système a l'airêtre fait
comme ça mais cela pourrait être
l'histoire de bon nombre d'entreprises
qui obtiennent des contrats
[Musique]
publics
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'ouverture de la dernière saison
des expos à Montréal en 2004 la firme de
gé conseil roche organise une fête
annuelle pour tout le gratin politique
Perm de prendre quelques minutes de
votre temps pour vous présenter nos
invités d'honneur une scène qu'on
reverrait probablement plus ces jourci
monur leader parlementaire du
gouvernement Monsieur Michel Bissonet
président de l'Assemblée nationale du
Québec Monsieur Jean-Marc Fournier
ministre des Affaires municipales du
sport et du loisir les politiciens du
provincial sont là du municipal aussi le
président du comité
exécutif Géral ma de Montréal et son
conseil Richard Marot maire de mascou
champion de tennis roche même offert les
services d'ivon Deschamps pour dérider
les invités entre les manches non non
j'ai parl
je P je mieux de pas
sub c'est l'occasion privilégé de
regrouper ns plus
fidè plusieurs politiciens de tous les
partis ont assisté au fil des ans à
cette fête privée du groupe
roche cette soirée à 75000 dollars c'est
l'idée de cet homme je me
présenteésidentvelement
desairesm
groupee allement pas avant scène comme
ce soir c'est un homme de l'ombre
spécialiste de l'organisation
d'élections et de financement
politique autre personne qui partipé
grand à cette victoire aujourd'hui
c'est Gilles Cloutier s'agite dans les
coulisses du pouvoir depuis les années
50 il a travaillé à l'élection de
nombreux candidats aux élections
municipales provinciales et
fédéral en 2000 le Bureau de la
concurrence découvre son rôle central
dans un cartel de dénigement il est mise
à l'amand c'est un homme qui incarne
beaucoup de choses que les Québécois
trouve désormais
inacceptaable pendant des mois nous
avons tenté de lui
parlersie il a fini par accepter pendant
10 ans entre 1995 et 2005 le rôle de
Gill Cloutier est de décrocher les
contrats pour
il distribue les cadeaux aux élus et
fonctionnaires et envoie les factures à
ses
patrons a des
allouettes du golf du golf clouti a
déclaré au policiers que les élus de
boisbant était particulièrement Friant
de ses petits cadeaux on parle de cadeau
je parle de
billet de spectacle ou de
sport sûement oui sement
à plusieurs reprises oh ben non là on va
donner à lui parce qu'il m don des
billet c'est comme aller prendre un
dîner avec quelqu'un tu pay le l tu
retournes der tu discutes bon même temps
tu transmets deux billet d' pour ses
enfants ou pour lui pu son
épouse c'est une femme de marketing de
se rapprocher de du candidat numéro 1
plusieurs politiciens ont aussi séjourné
dans une majestueuse maison de
villégiature dans charlevois loué par
Roche pendant plusieurs étés c'est pour
rendre nos mares plus prêt puis pour les
approcher c'est un outil de travail la
maison les gens venaient pour on est prê
après mais les cadeaux de roche au
politicien allent beaucoup plus loin que
des séjours avec panorama sur le fleuve
Gill Cloutier soutient avoir distribué
l'argent de Roch au parti politique dans
le but très clair de décrocher des
contrats est-ce que y a juste vous qui
au courant de ça ou il y a d'autres
monde chez Roch qui éta au courant de ça
che roche
oui je prenais pas la décision de qui
qui était au courant de ça Marv
côé monsieur Mar Yvan côé vice-président
exécutif affairire gouvernemental c'est
à marqu Yvan côté devenu haut dirigeant
chez Roche après sa carrière en
politique que Gill Cloutier envoyait ses
factures pour les cadeaux et
contributions
politiques j'ai fait une facture je m'
payé puis j'ai changé j'ai changé le
chèque j'ai retiré le cash quel est le
montant total que vous avez reçu en
argent comptant en coupure 120000 Marc
Yvan côé a été sur la Cellette pendant
la commission Gomery lorsqu'il a admis
avoir distribué à plusieurs candidats
l'élection fédérale de 97 de l'argent
conttent qu'il avait reçu du Parti
libéral du Canada sans poser de question
sur sa provenance au téléphone il nous a
dit qu'il n'était pas intéressé à nous
parler en 2010 laasq perquisitionne chez
Roche les policiers retrouvent une
lettre d'un haut dirigeant adressé à
marquivvan côé les contributions
politiques sont évoqué comme moyen de
décrocher des contrats 15 ans après ses
écrits France Michot vice-présidente est
confrontée à cette lettre il faut
toucher des activités telles que
publicité relation et contribution
politique
fédérale provinciale municipale et aut
la compagnie dit à
94 ça fait long
cultureise madame France Michot
vice-présidente principale adjointe
municipalité et secteur public France
Michot est ingénieur l'une des rares
femmes a occupé un poste de haute
direction dans le génie conseil selon la
preuve recueillie par Mar elle aurait
participé activement au financement des
partis politiques pour le compte de
roche en interrogatoire le policier la
confronte à la déclaration d'un
ingénieur de roche qu' supervis lil nous
dit il dit oui à la demande de France
mich j'ai fait des CHS pour le Parti
québécois à au moins TR reprises et une
fois au Parti libéral j'ai donné des CHS
personnels à France Michot et elle me
redonnait le montant total du CH en
argent
comptant é pour des montant entre 500
et000 France s'occupa de donner les aux
personnes responsable des partis soit
violette trpag pour le Parti libéral et
Ginette Boin pour le Parti
québécois le même ingénieur soutient
qu'il a obtenu de faux bonis pour
camoufler ses dons au partis
politiques pour ma part j'ai déjà obtenu
des bonis que j'ai redonné à France
Micho argent compent j'avais obtenu cet
argent recevant de roche de faux
bonis là France là j'ai bien beau pas
connaître mais quand ingénieur vient
dire des choses comme
ça c'est B on par en des choses làans
que je confortable que c'est vrai il y a
des choses làans
que des
choses vous AZ trouvé combien de
centaines de PR dans votre vie vous ah
des centaines tout le monde faisait ça
France mich succède marquvant côé comme
patronne de Gilles Cloutier au début des
années 2000 pour effectuer le premier
lancé du match il le fait plaisir
d'accueillir monsieur Gilles Cloutier
c'est à cette époque que Gilles Cloutier
aurait donné 25000 dollars en
financement politique au parti
Solidarité bois brillant du mère Poirier
et de sa successeur Sylvie Saint-Jean
puis Roche a obtenu quelques jours plus
tard le contrat de service professionnel
de l'usine d'épuration des eau au terme
de ce qui semble être une série de
manœuvres soigneusement
orchestré après la pause l'exmeress de
boisbant confronté à la preuve de la
police tu me dis qu' j'ai uneoccupe dans
mon parti tu viens de dire ou c'est pas
moi qui sil en avait c'est pas moi que
je suis pas
[Musique]
qui
[Applaudissements]
Sylvie Saint-Jean est devenue mairesse
et chef de son parti Solidarité bois
brillant par un concours de
circonstances c'est une mère de famille
engagée dans sa communauté qui travaille
comme éducatrice en garderie à l'été
2005 elle remplace au pied levés le
maire Robert Poirier qui démissionne à
l'élection l'automne suivant elle est
élue en promettant de régler le problème
de l'usine d'épuration des eau qui sent
mauvais et fonctionne mal attiré par
l'odeur alléchante de millions de
dollars de contrat plusieurs entreprises
don roche veulent se rapprocher de la
messe c'est qui la c'est
moi
pourquoi parce que je me suis fa
manipuler en plein processus d'appel
d'offreou soutient avoir don 2000 dollar
en financement
illégalusine5 syv saint-je Robert
Poirier
j'aiag qui est décédé aujourd'hui
l'organisateur politique de solidarité
boisant dis
mon on donne toujours ça l'organisateur
principal trouir
c'est on transmetes arg à cette personne
g Cloutier soutient qu'il a fait une
fausse facture pour camoufler le 25000
dollar qui aurait été payé par
Roch
ils mais tu lu demandé de garder un
tableau Excel all en
cour c'est sûr c'est son mais ça F de
comprendre selon le témoignage d'un haut
fonctionnaire de la ville de boisbriant
certaines firmes étaient clairement
favorisé dans le temps de syv Saint-Jean
c'était BPR et roche ces consultants
étaient choisis par le politique parce
qu'ils étaient derrière la gagne de
slivi Saint-Jean avant d'octroyer le
contrat pour l'usine un comité devait
évaluer la conformité des soumissions ce
comité était formé de l'ami d'enfance de
l'ancien maire Robert Poirier d'un
militant de son parti et de son
organisateur politique Jean gu Gagnon
celui- làà même qui aurait reçu les
25000 dollars de roche l'idé était pipé
selon un membre du comité est-ce que le
contrat des plans et devis était
prédestiné à une firme en particulier
oui à Roche Jean gu Gagnon nous appela à
la maison pour nous dire d'avance qui
avait le plus beau projet Roche a même
fourni au comité un exemple de grille
pour évaluer les candidatures en clair
Roche a proposé les critères qui ont
servi à évaluer sa propre candidature le
comité a éliminé toutes les firmes sauf
Roch et BPR Triax qui se serait ensuite
entendu sur le prix de leur soumission
selon des employés des deux
entreprises je lui ai parlé avec un code
que j'avais inventé je lui ai dit que
son facteur de sécurité pour l'usine de
boisbriant était de 1 point quelque
chose pour nous deux c'était clair que
ce chiffre correspondait au montant
auquel il devait soumissionner
ce montant était supérieur à notre
submission donc je muroche obtienne le
controute je
rersé Vpr Triax et roche se serait
partagé d'autres contrat de la même
façon selon l'enquête policière il y a
eu des contrats curé Boivin côte sud et
boulevard des entreprises qui éta
destiné à Roche les projets grand all
grande côte é qu à eux destinés à BP
Triax dire vous savez
que quandon parlait là le ma c'est comme
B vous vous avez ça ça ça tout ça ça ça
tout le monde est content vous
fournissez au parti pu c'est même ça
marche c'est même à beaucoup de place
France et ce serait donc sans surprise
qu'en octobre 2005 roche obtient le
contrat de génie de l'usine au montant
d'1549387 dollars beaucoup plus cher que
ce que la ville avait prévu l'appel
d'offre pour trouver une entreprise qui
fera à la construction peut maintenant
commencer 26 entreprises se sont procuré
les documents nécessaires à la
soumission mais Infrabec l'entreprise de
linosambito et mystérieusement le seul
soumissionnaire à 28 millions de dollars
5 millions plus cher que l'estimé de
rocheissnaire conform m'y la
[Musique]
j la police a retrouvé chez infrabeec la
liste des soumissionnaires potentiels
qui lui aurait été envoyé par Roche
pendant la période d'appel d'offre je
sais que France Michot est en contact
régulièrement avant avant le dépôt de la
soumission avec les nous zitau on va
s'expliquer en justice puis ça tiendra
puis ça tiendra pas on
verra puisqueinfrabeec était le seul
soumissionnaire la ville aurait pu
aisément annuler l'appel d'offre mais
elle a demandé l' vie de roche 7lion.5
million avec avec les taxes et vous avez
fait des calculs selon l'enquête
policière gu Morin ingénieur che roche
aurait produit un calcul erroné qui
justifia le prix d'infrabeec aux yeux
des élus de bois brillant il le ni
catégoriquement c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai
[Musique]
mon-m mon
ave on va tout sortir le dossier on va
prendre tout l'histoire du dossier et
jusque
l'analyse on va prendre toute l'histoire
si vousz fait si vous l' fait
monsie sera
position ce qui ajouterait l'insulte à
l'injure c'est que le groupe proche
aurait fait augmenter ses honoraires
d'un demi million supplémentaires en
fonction du prix du contrat de
construction
[Musique]
d'infrabeec en octobre 2009 enquête
avait révélé les liens de proximité
entre l'INO imbito et la messe Sylvie
Saint-Jean zambitou est notamment accusé
de complot pour abus de confiance parce
qu'infrabeec aurait financé de la
formation des sondages et un site web
pour la messe et son parti les
politiciens ou les gens
autorité il ont pe d'une chos à part des
votesu quoi il on pe d'une chose on pe
de gens comme toi en dépit des
accusation contre lui il veut témoigner
des problèmes qui découlent selon lui du
financement des partis politiques
qu'est-ce que je
trouve le plus pervers c'est queon
essaie de faire à croire que c'est un
financement vraiment
public
puis
on on prend les gens pour des
cruches avec le groupe Roche linoambito
a été au cœur d'une grande opération de
charme auprès de l'ancienne ministre des
Affaires municipales natthalie normando
de qui dépendait la subvention pour
l'usine de bois
brillant après la pause un entrepreneur
qui refuse d'être le Bou émissaire de
tout un système une mascarade c'est
c'est une pièce de théâtre la loi leur
permet de dépenser 100000 mais les
élections en coûtent 2
300000 c'est de
[Musique]
l'hypocrisie on avait espéré que dans le
fonctionnement d'une société
démocratique il n'est probablement rien
de plus indispensable que la crédibilité
des institutions politiques en
1977 René Levac voulait mettre les
politiciens à l'abri des groupes
d'intérêt l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
une loi qui empêche les entreprises de
contribuer au partis politiqu depuis ce
temps le Québec se targue d'être un
modèle de financement populaire des
partis politiques une mascarade
une pièce de théâtre la loi leur
permet de dépenser 100000 mais les
élection en coûte 2
300000 c'est de l'hypocrisie que ça coû
après plusieurs demandes linoambitou a
finalement accepté de nous accorder une
entrevue à la condition de ne pas parler
des faits pour lequel il est accusé j'ai
assisté à des cocktails du Parti libéral
j'ai assisté à des cocktails du Parti
québécois j'ai assist à des cocktails de
l'action mocratif au fédéral j'ai
contribué Parti libéral du Canada j'ai
contribué aussi au Parti conservateur le
bloc oui je pense que oui je pense que
oui ce n'est pas vraiment par conviction
que linoito comme plusieurs
entrepreneurs en construction a
contribué d'importantes sommes à
plusieurs partis politiques ça c'est mon
opinion à moi avec qu'est-ce que j'ai vu
j'ai vécu il y a trop de
proximité entre le financement les
donneurs d'ouvrage et les gens qui font
la surveillance s chantiers c'est roche
qui surveillait infrabeec dans sa
construction de l'usine de traitement
des EAU des aides puis éventuellement
ils vont t'aider si tu as besoin d'aide
c'est c'est pas
sorcier en novembre 2006 Roch organise
un cocktail de financement politique
pour Natalie normando linosito achète
plusieurs billets Roche a déjà le
contrat de l'usine mais il faut une
subvention du gouvernement du Québec
pour que le projet aille de l'avant pas
de subvention pas d'usine puis ce soir
là pendant la soirée les gens de la
ville de Brian se sont fait annoncer que
il y avait eu la subvention comm FRUD
c'est ça ce qu' fait àri faitter la
subvention ça a aidé à d'avoir
rencontré des gens au cabinet de la
ministre norando puis a eu un montant
supplémentaire ça a coûtéille marché à
ville puis ça a fait l'affaire de Madame
saint-jec pour obtenir cette subvention
France Michou et Sylvie Saint-Jean ont
rencontré le chef de cabinet de Nathalie
normando en juin 2006 de semaines plus
tard une note indique que le projet ira
de l'avant pourtant les fonctionnaires
du ministère avaient à plusieurs
reprises recommandé le rejet de la
subvention c'est arrivé parfois madame
Denis que j'ai fait passer des
projets alors que ça fitait pas dans la
petit car communiste ben on essaie de
faire preuve la plus grande souplesse et
créativité possible j'assume totalement
ce que j'ai fait roche organise des
financements pour Nathalie normando en
2005 2006 2007 et 2008 selon la preuve
policière France Michot aurait venté ses
contacts en politique pour vendre la
candidature de roche à bois
brillant foisavention ça jamaché toutoup
desou c'est bon
cont techque-ce que c'est lié la
subvention le financement pour de
Roch ou le ministre des Affaires
municipales est important la subvention
gros m pour la F de
G
conc après avoir obtenu le contrat de
construction de l'usine Lino Zambito
organise lui aussi son activité de
financement pour Nathalie normandau en
janvier 2008 on était je te dirais une
vingtaine de personnes à peu près 20 25
personnes est-ce qu'il y avait des gens
de roche ce soirl oui les gens de roche
cétait là est-ce que les gens les élus
de boisbriant étaient là ce soirl oui il
y avait un élu de bois linousitou
soutient qu'il a recueilli au moins
100000 dollars lors de cette soirée même
mme si les rapports officiels du
directeur général des élections et du
Parti libéral font état de seulement
77500 dollars au bamot Infrabec et roche
ont recueilli des centaines de milliers
de dollars pour natthalie normando qui a
autorisé une subvention de 11 millions
de dollars contre la vie de ses
[Musique]
fonctionnaires l'ex-ministre des
Affaires municipal a aussi accepté
l'invitation de Lino Zambito au
spectacle de Céline Dion centre en 2008
Zito a offert billets à la ministre et
son entourage est-ce que vous savez qui
a payé vos vos billet ce soir là
sincèrement on a eu des
billets mais je pourrais pas vous dire
je pourrais pas vous dire je pourrais
pas vous dire c'est linambit qui a payé
vos billets ce soir ok c'était pas mon
habitude d'aller dans les dans les loges
là c'est ça céit vraiment l'exception
bon cion quand même
[Musique]
et Nathalie normando nous a admis avoir
reçu d'autres billets de spectacle de
Lino Zambito est-ce qu'il vous a offert
des billets oui il a offert des billets
pour le spectacle de Madon puis je vais
arrêter de répondre à vos questions
Marie MAE parce que je pense que j'ai
assez collaboré jusqu'à maintenant je
peux réitérer fortement le fait que un
je n'avais pas de lien spéciaux avec
monan bito et deuxièmement ça n'a
influencé en aucun temps mon travail de
ministre on pvait pas avoir un mandat on
donit pas des sous
élection a eu des m on Ava fait quel
chose
d'organisation
pay c'est
don pour
savoir ça marcha comme ça c système
selon linit les entreprises de
construction n'ont pas vraiment le choix
d'aider les firmes de gé conseil FINC
les partis politiques les firmes
d'ingénieurs ont c'est les gens qui sont
les plus proches du pouvoir donc par
après ils ont sûrement du financement à
faire et tenté de de d'aller chercher du
financement pour ses parties politique
là j'étais tout le temps persuadé que en
les aidant dans dans leur
financement sont un peu mal placé de le
lendemain de te de d'essayer de
t'écraser il y a deux façons surveiller
des travaux il y a une façon qu'on prend
le le devis puis on l'applique à la
lettre puis a une façon de d'appliquer
le devis et sans vouloir saigner
l'entrepreneur aujourd'hui linos Ito a
quitté la construction son entreprise
Infrabec est en faillite il attend son
procès et veut se défendre des
accusations vous êtes pas un purure
innocent non plus he monsieur Cloutier
non je suis pas un innocent vous en avez
profité j'en ai profité j'ai eu des
beaux emplois trèss bien rénumérés j'ai
fait de l'argent avec ça malgré son rôle
central dans l'affaire bois brillant
Gill Cloutier n'a pas été accusé
probablement parce qu'il a été l'un des
premiers à collaborer avec la police moi
j'ai décidé de de dire ce que je savais
j'ai décidé de parler à Marte c'était la
seule façon
de de ramener les choses de ce fameux là
là qu'un jour ou l'autre ça
arrête ceux qui me traitent de mental
c'est parce que sont pas décidés à
parler encore l'ancien maire de
boisbriant Robert Poirier nous a dit
qu'il n'avait rien à se reprocher il
croit qu'il est accusé parce que le
gouvernement du Québec a mis de la
pression pour que l'esquad marteau
frappe un grand coup Sylvie Saint-Jean
Claude Brière rosire fontaine Guan Morin
JP Zambito et France Michot ont refusé
de nous parler pour pour ne pas nuire à
leur procès roche qui a refusé toutes
nos demandes d'entrevue nous a dit
espéré que la Commission charbonau fera
la lumière et invite les gens à y
participer mais moi on m'a dit tu parles
pas tuattends tu as des choses à on a
des choses à vous dire on va dire avec
l'avoc on t'accuse on t'arrête on
t'amène au postes on t'assis sur une
chaise mais ferme ta boî puis avale ta
pelule puis sur nous autres on va te
défendre le mieux qu'on peut bonne
chance c'est sûr c pas correct ce que
j'ai fait mais comme je te disais tantôt
le
système le système était déjà établi
quand j'ai commencé à faire de ça
gouvernement surveillait pas les les
personnes
surveillaient les gens faisaient ce
voulent j'ai rien fait pour moi
que qui va dire que j'ai fait quelque
chose de mal j'avis j'étais consciente
que je faisais quelque chose de groche
mais faut que çaarrête non arrête parce
qu'aujourd'hui France là faut que tu
penses à toi non pas à Roche pas à
personne d'aut tu
penses
là des ingénieurs une messe des chef
d'entreprise des gens qui auraient fait
partie d'un système qui existe depuis
des décennies un juge qui aura entendu
toute la preuve et leur défense décidera
s'ils sont responsables et à quel
degré
[Musique]